And we must take back the profession of healing.
From science because you see it's medical science is not healing profusion.
It's a profession which manages it seems to me. In the body. And that's not healing and.
I don't believe in healing because they believe in it in the context of. Wounds healing for example. But that.
There is a healing. Intelligence within the body. Which can be a stude by natural me to sins.
Who is totally outside of the science and the realm of experience. But then i feel that because of the.
Orthodoxy of the training. I have the rot. To pass judgment on. A natural clear petes.
It's almost not like you i have a god given right it's not being him
or not you know you have a god given right to rule. Because if you will do in your place in society.
And it i have no qualms about exiting match. Role and. I don't think i will.
I don't know that i'm not to speak to you say to you that the doing the right thing by society they certainly are not
supposed to have to justify the. Sixty thousand dollars or whatever it is even.
By continuing to be going into bureaucrats and. Create regulations and need to slash and it's.
I mean what would we do with them. Nor do i think natural medicines would look well.
What people forget is that human beings are part of nature. That really have a goal. On this clangers.
Along with all the plants and all the enemy. And the atmosphere in the water. The minerals. Together and.
Consequently when she laughs you. Still laugh systems and.
It's something that four million news human beings leave on this planet.
And we're not you know coolants with the natural. Cycles of the seasons and the things that grew.
So it has developed us. We haven't developed. And now. We totally cut off from that and we don't leave.
Within a natural cycle. We for example. It seems only ran it should only be in for a short time with you like tomatoes.
Very irritating. To the system and. A lot of people are allergic to them.
And yet we expect them to have them on a table in the dative when test. And often.
We totally out of touch with our bodies we get messages that we completely missing to produce and we ignore.
We don't know what to do. When we get them. Don't know how to heal that's. We've broken away from nature.
And the system which grew us and naresh to us and use the tecate to bring us back to it. A healthy state. We've lost.
Lost it.
And i mean even in the early parts of the century there was a lot of knowledge you cite me to some people couldn't
afford to go to doctors that a lot of people knew how to heal themselves with foods and who raced in.
Things like that that we have lost. And it to me a big part of natural. Pieces the.
Education the read you cation of people in the traditional. Grass roots medicine which is very. I think to even useful.
And people need it. Nowadays people get you.
And i want to go somewhere
and take a pill get a pill that will enable him to stop it we create sample i don't want to take five days off in reste
and maybe faster a couple of days and just hang. Vegetables and fruit and.
Retreating to themselves and think about the.
Stresses in the life direction and why they get in you and things like that.
I just want to ignore that totally and take a pill and have it will go away.
And the medical profession has encouraged the martially. In that response because that's where the health dollar yes.
That's what it's all the bad to the name. They want that responsibility. They want people to come to the complaint.
Online now the health system is getting i well with people who have been conditioned to do exactly that and now.
Just the other day i heard it on the radio that they wanted to encourage people to think before they go to the doctor
about whether the a complaint is really a trivial one
and they might be able to take care of it themselves because the system is getting either way and.
The spiritual side of healing well. You know since theories no spiritual side of healing because if you always do.
Practitioner the reason i do fusion. Mind body and spirit or into it was even through a recent.
And add being so high that you dispute your component you will need that and lodge bell component to your thoughts.
So that people don't for example imagine that you can treat depression.
Three natural medicine
but you can just the same as if you treating physical complaints you often have to get into the emotional i speak till.
Them so they really isn't any division and. But we really stuck with the mind body split.
Which again is sort of developed in the last three hundred years. Through.
County asian philosophy three being really locked into the physical. That stan ye we explode for three hundred years.
And we need just this century studying to explore. The mind without infringe proficiency of psychiatry and psychology.
And even people who are involved in natural medicine don't really realize a lot of the time.
I get clients that come to me who just want people to fix the problem so that it can go away
and they can get back to work and i think that the.
Practicing opportunity of medicine by doing that but they don't realize. Really what holistic medicine. Means.
On a personal level. But getting back to spiritual healing.
They certainly use such thing as spiritual healing in a way people. Achieve healing through.
Lying on of hands through premier through meditation. And really the talk of healing has to suit the pearson you can't.
Force a person to take up a particular approach to healing people have to do what they feel is right for the name.
And then of course they do. So that's why you know and the wonderful thing really about is trying to use that that.
We have pretty much freedom of choice. We think what type of medicine we are in child providing we can afford it.
Is germane to sort of financial discrimination against.
Natural therapies because people have to pay for the math of the package. But the fact is that they do.
I mean they support. A growing. Natural therapies industry.
And of their own pockets and it's now is to my good to be with. I dunno half a billion dollars a year.
She was trying to get that was a figure that the australian natural therapist association came up with.
And that includes. Not any consultations but. When the manufacturing side of it. For example.
Health food store was a huge and growing industry which is beginning to have an impact on our economy. So i think that.
We must retain that choice we have to have all types of healing available to people from spiritual healing to natural
medicine to orthodox. Scientific medicine. And it is a place for all of them. Certainly because of manu singhvi.
Grandon pretty familiar with what orthodox medicine. Can achieve and i would never say. We must not have it.
But it's place really. It's dramatic medicine it's acute medicine it's risk you. Emergency.
It deals with things when they've gotten so out of hand. That the posts not chi nor anyone else. Capable of healing.
And you get stuck to that role that would be great but it strives to state being to situations and. There are so many.
You know chronic in suffolk you complaints which are amenable to healing. But that people when they go to war the dogs.
Me to sing. Don't get healing they get management. Which involves taking drugs. Maybe for the rest of your life.
And while they may sustain you a lot for some time with that they actually take years off your life
and launching into question what the quality of your life is is another mattia and. It also takes that takes. You.
The prospect of healing. Away. Takes responsibility for the individual for the health. Away.
But the face of all kinds of medicine is changing dramatically you know straight in and it's very exciting.
He's mentally onus. Probably the most interesting development in that area would be with the.
Sorry orthomolecular medicine. Which is a branch of. Orthodox medicine. But they only use.
What i described as natural medicines like vitamins and minerals for example.
And they realize that they do rely on science for the. And the foundings. Research.
Said that most of the things they practice could have been backed up by research so that's another interesting
development within the ranks of. Orthodox medicine. As far as natural therapies are consumed.
And then their role in the. It into mental illness. I don't think a lot of natural therapists treat.
Serious mental illnesses. You know that. The sort of groups that have psychotic manifestations.
But certainly amongst the. The neurotic. Therapy used at that sorry. Disorders there's probably a fee.
Representation of natural therapies and by that i would include things like. Psychology which is a natural therapy.
Rebirthing. Various therapies. Apartment and mineral therapy.
A lot of people go to natural therapists for stressed and sleeplessness. Anxieties. Things like bad.
So then we're kind of monday and day to day.
Emotional disorders astute and they approached by natural therapies but the most serious ones. On the home. So.
Yes touch is really important and healing. In a lot of people go to natural therapists who do body would.
On a regular basis because. Often it's the only sort of touching that they get. And this.
This particular theme has really been taken up within the new singh profession. For example say with. Paper.
You know singing hymns and the recognition that they are very deprived of physical contact. So that they you know.
Increasingly with the news sometimes for example there are programs to incorporate message.
Reflexology a rhyme a series things like that that include. That have deiced on touch.
I guess a lot of that just goes back to the sort of society that we live in we have a lot of conflict
and confusion iran and the body. Touch.
Sick surely she said it was natural to be certainly plays a new role in providing match was
and that's been a difficult thing for the message to do because three example you often get confused with people who
provide. Six you'll seuss's. To some people when. You know it. From the public perception. Messages a sexual event.
And yet that's not what most bodywear can see themselves as providing they are honest the way i would look at it is
that there's a big difference between its. Sensuality and touch. And six you ality.
Their different sort of things going on. And and touch. I mean it still can be. Through its sensuality.
Through the magnetic transference of energy. Through its counterfeiting. Can be extremely healing.
And that's a very different thing from the sort of that six woman things that one gets from sitting on the tops of them.
People who provide physical say this is.
We don't differentiate between those sorts of things very easily we haven't talked about it in the neck culture and.
Message wasn't a part of their culture. Prior to a few decades ago.
And i think it's sort of part of that the freeing up of the whole body thing. Basically in a society which.
I think is very important and. It's going through all kinds of. Phases.
In its manifestation some of them quite horrible.
But it's you know i think basically it's really necessary that we free up a lot of area to choose to the body.
They've being making it's on all sorts of levels. Will sink she realities to something we can't sleep or a dash.
You know we have. I mean we've been repressed that it's been taboo for a long time and now it's.
Emerging as a very positive and being in something that we need to explore and heal. And you know.
As i said it's just do. I think it's a nice theory part of the whole kind of taking responsibility for one's healing.
Thing and. For example sexual issues are responsible for a lot of marriage breaks that. Break ups.
Because people go into sexual relationships with so many of knowledge.
That especially when you young sadly experienced and. They can be different state ing people. And we don't do enough.
Teaching of those sorts of things you know nice young people. And all of that.
Those issues are really fruit because they become bound up with moral. Into pretensions of reality.
And we don't have a simple straightforward. Comfortable. Experience without bodies a lot of the town. Rituals.
I mean tombs of. Groups in tombs of which shops. Just relating to sick she reality.
There's some of that sort of healing with it going on in this syria. There are means groups in which shops happening.
Within the context of rebasing. For example as a therapy sexual issues often come up for people with those kind of.
Psychological therapies like that part of the issues they're really fundamental to a lot of people's problems and.
So they can that.
And use theory which she see advertised around from challenging time on a stick she reality and relationships.
It's not my particular area so i don't know a lot about how those which shops around. But c.s. They do a coup.
Whether it's more in this area than in the big cities i don't know maybe not. I think it. I think.
We're certainly kind of dropping out of society. It's very confronting and. The reason a lot of. You know growth.
And exploration. Goes on up here. I mean amongst the people that are there. It's just sort of.
Second nature to be talking about adding a lot of sin. With the challenges that confront us on that level.
And i don't know how much that goes on in wider society i know.
It's certainly increasing i mean you can pick up all sorts of magazines and things like that
and find out it was that reflect that interest the personal growth movement. And that's a very important component.
For example of marriage guidance. Associations. And certainly it's a really important aspect of lesia.
I think that when people it's not men's loz hierarchy of needs once people's basic needs to meet food food shelter.
Security on a move physical level when we become free to explore other issues you can pierce no growth really
when you're stabbing somali. It's not an issue. But up at we people have more time. And certainly i think. Now.
With so many people unemployed. And sam many people are facing issues such as streets.
There was a story on the radio the other day that have many more mena going along.
To council is about stresses in the laws particularly with the recession. And loss of income and things like that and.
So sydney people are tuning in wood and. Looking at themselves in the way they. Act two. Life situations.
And not simply reacting and acting at. And being out of touch with what they doing.
They actually thinking about the way they react to things and questioning them so so that we can all react differently.
Cannot look at the situation in a more positive lot and you know.
Do i have to feel i have a will out of it what can i do you to tune this into a creative situation that.
That kind of thinking. Does happen a lot up here and. There's a lot of innovative small businesses for example.
In mysteria. And that's being encouraged you know. With government money. Desperate times.
You so i think that the whole precipitous no growth no movement.
Is to the forefront he had been certainly also growing in the wider society. Thank you. And would. The rest.
Well random been it's been. Quite a strong tradition for the last twenty. Natural birth and hind shoes.
And that was initiated by mothers the. He could not get anybody to attain the booths at hand. And.
So a group of women who believed that they should have the rotch. To a natural booth.
No one and not have a need to syria intervention.
Saw that the only way they could do that was to try and sue
and provide themselves with that syria this which they need.
And most of those lame midwives are competent and will train and responsible and have very good statistics.
In the care of mothers. The idle to pick up when there's a problem and transfer they have a hard transfer you right.
Then. Qualified midwives. In other words they tend to transfuse suna. Yes they've just been deemed to be illegal.
You new south wales.
And that's very threatening from birth
and beyond in nimbin because they have lodged an organization which has depended upon.
And i need wives and booth assistants to provide kin and support.
And with that them who think beyond itself might be in jeopardy and.
Easiness trainee one of the few examples of successful community development in health.
As in is that as it as an organized. It is the end i deal in timbs of what the world health.
Which is to promote right around the world. We as what they call primary health care and putting health care.
Into the hands of the community. Who think beyond have been doing that before cheney.
And now that send three age because of the new says. We just ration will be new south wales and.
He basically had for magid this is an issue of safety. And yet that can't be proven. And the opposite. Has been shine.
There have been the odd limeade wives to be done. Way at things and have jeopardized. The issue of lying we free for.
Other. More numerous and more responsible people. But the noose is registration fraud.
I'm not sure if i've got the right name of the association a bit. Anyway the professional associations of nooses.
Have totally i've looked to for example the right of women to choose. The health care practitioners.
He not an official health care practitioners. They have totally of a loop which the wood health organizations.
Philosophy. With three guide to traditional medicine and i mean we free.
If these women who are practicing law i mean we exist today in africa india. They would be lauded for the activities.
They would be assisted with government grants.
They would be assisted with educational programs that he had they simply. Denigrated ostracized. Made illegal.
Threatened with jail and fines. Why. No. Yes. It was. It was. Well as. The i made was.
Along with most would say hi i'm booth midwives qualified ones. Very much holistic practitioner. And that really.
Influences. Dramatically the way they approach it as a life event. The path for impact. For the family involved.
And interestingly enough if you look at any new seeing course and.
In fact the nuisance registration board itself defines new thing as a not as well as a science.
They promote holistic nursing and they promote the actual use of inchy we shouldn. Off ones.
You know knowing that develops over time with. Exposure to people in the healing. And health professions.
But in the hospital with this there isn't room. Very much for this to happen. The people who are actually doing it.
Tend to be those holistic nursing.
Practitioners who operate outside the system such as nuisance who move into natural medicine. Nuisance to be county.
Made wives who become practitioners. And women often mothers who take up. And i mean we free.
Being booth assistants they the ones who are truly providing holistic. It's an interesting arni well.
Way that mead was using she was in for example ina booth.
He most often comes that we get situations of delight we mothers seem to get stuck.
Now i know i fear the dilation and civic spirit. An arrow to move. And we the whole process seems to be boiled down.
Now if you were in hospital what would happen would be they'd put up a drip in putting oxytocin to stimulate the user
it's in. Speed the whole process up with a drug membranes they'd probably be the nine approaches.
So it's kitted a very physical. Prices. But. Holistic midwives. Would look at that situation and wonder.
Was this something blocking the person. The mother involved. And i would white. They would talk.
They would use all kinds of. Comforting mages. Everything from say hot towels for physical pain to touch. Message.
Providing a really safe and loving environment for the mother to get into his stuff
and explore on an emotional level what's going on along with standard observation. Of mother in baby you know.
Feel right all of those sorts of things to make sure that things were going well
and were remaining within normal limits. And you get breakthroughs in those situations for example i was at a booth.
Semi's ago we. The woman involved was running a business. And she was the mainstay of that business.
And who knew a bit about it but she was really deep down considering that.
At the conflict between who having to start hearing volved in the business and just be. In the other and.
With that was going to be eye candy and. So she got to transition and she just bought and.
She was very recent educated and anxious and. Crawling around on the beach through a narrow something this went on.
And when we just laid it being we took two and we cuddled there and we. You know.
Tried to help you get down into it and finally she just boost at with it. We think.
The woods is it ok for me to be the mother. And we all said yes.
So it's a can and with that she just went straight into second stage and both did. Well.
She just lit guy then and she started to be a baby and she sat up. You know sort of meditation position and she stayed.
After you know a few more minutes have just come and relax and she said i feel all full of light.
And then nobody came out. And those sort of situations just don't happen. Very really you know hospital.
And that's why we even choose him days. That's why a lot of meat was going to home.
Because they can be real authentic midwives. They can be creative.
Spiritually and emotionally as well as competent responsible. Practitioners taking care of the physical. Want to be.